there's been just a small tangent a lot
of discussion about hypersonic nuclear
weapons like ra missiles from you know
russia
uh bragging about that is this something
that's a significant concern or is it
just a way to flex about different kinds
of weapon systems
hypersonics i do think pose a challenge
for our detection systems because there
are
um
you know there are design considerations
in these sensor systems as always right
and when you build them and the
technology progresses to a point where
maybe it's not feasible to use that
technology you know there's a problem
but with the
you know the all domain and kind of
cross domain data linking capabilities
we have um
it's less of you know
it's more of an integrated picture i'll
say um and so the hypersonics um
are really what it is is uh how fast can
we detect and destroy problems you're
just shortening the time available to do
that we call something like that the
kill chain right it's it's from um
locating a target and identifying it and
you know essentially authorizing its
destruction by whatever means uh
employing and then actually following up
to ensure that you did what you said you
were going to do in some sense right
doesn't need another re-attack something
of that nature
and so
there's an old dog fighting framework
you could call it it's called the ooda
loop that kind of made its way in the
engineering of business now but the old
observe orientate side act was initially
a a fighter mechanism in order to get
inside that kill chain of your opponent
and break it up so that he can't
uh process his kill chain on you and so
hypersonic's a way of shortening those
those windows of opportunity to to react
to that
i wonder what do like how much do you
have to shorten it in order for
the defense systems not to work anymore
it seems like uh
it's very you know i
i'm both often horrified by the thought
of nuclear war
but at the same time
wonder
what that looks like
when i dream of extreme competence in
defense systems i imagine that not a
single nuclear weapon can reach the
united states by missile
with the defense system
defense systems but then again i also
understand that these are extremely
complicated systems the amount of
integration required and because you're
not using them
i mean this is exactly
there could be you know there's like an
intern somewhere
that like forgot to update the code the
fortran code that like is going to be
make the difference because you don't
have the opportunity to really
thoroughly test
which is really scary of course the
systems are probably incredible
if they could be tested but because they
can't be really thoroughly tested in
actual
um
in an actual attack i wonder
i mean i guess one assumption there
would be that these hypersonic missiles
would only be launched and the case
would attack
um it'd be interesting if there were
other hypersonic objects that we could
use to flex those systems
you